madame la présidente madame la première
ministre
j'avais fait un rêve celui que vous
entendiez le message des urnes qui a
forgé cette nouvelle assemblée oui
j'avais rêvé que vous compreniez le sens
du vote du 19 juin son caractère
exceptionnel
pourquoi le peuple français deux mois
après le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous a refusé la majorité
oui j'imagine est sans doute naïvement
que ce désaveu populaire sans précédent
vous aurez conduit à entendre la
souffrance des français étranglé par
l'inflation vous auriez pu par exemple
aujourd'hui nous proposer une vraie
baisse du prix du carburant la tva à
taux zéro sur les produits de première
nécessité l'indexation durable des
pensions de retraite sur l'inflation
une baisse des charges salariales pour
augmenter le salaire net mesures qui
pourraient être financés par la taxation
des supers profits des profiteurs de
crise par une vraie lutte contre les
gaspillages colossaux de la fraude à la
carte vitale ou l'évasion fiscale dégâts
femme mesure j'en suis certain qu'ils
auraient été approuvées sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée mais vous
préférez vos vieilles rustine les fameux
chèque qui ne compense pas la hausse de
l'inflation et qui font baisser le
pouvoir d'achat des français et l'on
retrouve les grosses ficelles de
communication du précédent quinquennat
sans doute soufflé par mckinsey pour
vous donner bonne conscience tout en
gagnant du temps
alors oui j'imagine est aussi que vous
prendriez conscience de la gravité du
déficit extérieur record de la france
des difficultés de nos artisans et de
nos pme car l'enjeu majeur vous le savez
c'est de produire local seul moyen de
réduire la fracture territoriale de
rééquilibrer nos comptes extérieurs et
de protéger vraiment la planète mais là
aussi on retrouve la marque de fabrique
de la macro ni des demi mesures pour du
en même temps est plutôt que de réduire
fortement les charges de nos pme des
entrepreneurs patriotes qui produisent
en france qui relocalisent vous prêts
verts sz préféré déversé toujours plus 2
milliards d'euros une union européenne
qui financent nos concurrents signent
des accords de libre-échange déloyaux et
nous entraîne vers la guerre alors oui
oui j'imagine est aussi que vous auriez
voulu combattre vraiment l'insécurité en
changeant enfin de politique pénale mais
là encore vous restez sourds et aveugles
vous annoncer des mesures pour la police
et la gendarmerie très bien mais vous
avez préféré reconduire le garde des
sceaux celui qui préfère est applaudie
dans nos prisons que plutôt que de
défendre les victimes et je ne parle
même pas de l'immigration où là encore
vous ne proposer aucun changement de cap
réel enfin j'imagine est un vrai plan de
sauvetage de nos services publics
principalement pour reconstruire l'école
et l'hôpital public en métropole comme
outre-mer et là aussi une énième fois
quelle déception toujours les mêmes
poncifs les discours creux sur
l'éducation nationale alors que les
classements internationaux nous
ridiculisent d'année en année nous avons
tant besoin d'un sursaut pour l'école de
la république passant par des
enseignants mieux payés et par des
programmes beaucoup plus exigeants quant
à l'hôpital tout le monde aura compris
en vous écoutant que vous ne changera
rien à la politique qui a supprimé 17
1300 lits en cinq ans et pire vous vous
refusez à réintégrer les soignants
scandaleusement exclu alors qu'il en
manque tant en vous écoutant pour
conclure madame le premier ministre j'ai
compris pourquoi vous n'avez pas osé
demander la confiance à l'assemblée
nationale à partir du moment mes chers
collègues ou le président macron et vous
même refusé d'entendre l'avertissement
populaire des urnes dès lors et des
lords infléchir votre projet pour nous
rassembler ici de bords différents
autour de quelques mesures fortes pour
le pouvoir d'achat notamment des
français dans un élan de salut public
auquel nous étions prêts vous saviez que
vous n'aviez pas de majorité ici vous
aviez pourtant l'occasion historique
d'écouter d'entendre de proposer un
nouveau cap
réconciliant les français à travers nous
en vous arc boutant sur le projet
mort-né d'emmanuel macron vous commettez
une très grave faute vous préférez la
facilité politicienne en voulant rejeté
la responsabilité du blocage du pays sur
l'opposition sur les oppositions alors
que ce blocage ne tient qu'à la vague le
mans la surdité d'un président de la
république minoritaire dans son propre
pays
franchement franchement
auriez vous auriez vous prononcez
mercier vous prononcer un discours
différent si beau si l'assemblée
nationale avait une majorité absolue
en deux mois si vous avez perdu la
confiance des français